>>> IN JUST A MATTER DAYS, TWO
WOMEN WERE INJURED IN BISON
ATTACKS WHILE VISITING NATIONAL
PARKS.
SATURDAY IN NORTH DAKOTA A WOMAN
SUFFERED INJURIES TO HER STOMACH
AND WHEN BISON CHARGED HERP.
ON MONDAY, A BISON GORED A WOMAN
IN WYOMING.
BOTH WERE SEPTEMBER TO HOSPITALS
TO BE TREATED FOR THEIR INJURIES
AND INVESTIGATIONS INTO THE
ATTACKS ARE ONGOING.
JOINING US NOW WITH MORE INSIGHT
INTO THIS IS YELLOWSTONE
WILDLIFE SAFARI GUIDE GRANT
TRCHLT JOHNSON.
GRANT, WOW.
THIS SOUNDS REALLY SCARY AND
BOTH OF THESE INCIDENTS ARE
DIFFERENT, BUT I WONDER, ARE
PEOPLE JUST GETTING TOO CLOSE TO
THESE ANIMALS OR IS SOMETHING
ELSE HAPPENING HERE?
>> SO, OVERWHELMINGLY, THE
INCIDENCES BETWEEN BISON AND
PEOPLE ARE A RESULT OF PEOPLE
GETTING TOO CLOSE TO THE
ANIMALS.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A BIT OF A
CONVERGENCE OF WHO FACTORS.
FIRST, THE BEGINNING OF THE
BISON RUT, THE MATING SEASON.
SO BOTH THE MALE AND FEMALE
BISON HAVE ELEVATED LEVELS OF
HORMONES AND THAT MAKES THEM A
LITTLE BIT MORE AGITATED, A
LITTLE BIT MORE COMPETITIVE ON
THE LANDSCAPE.
SECONDLY, JULY IS THE BUSIEST
MONTH FOR PEOPLE TO BE VISITING
THE NATIONAL PARKS.
SO THE RISK OF BEING ATTACKED BY
A BISON OR ANY OTHER ANIMAL IS
OUTRAGEOUSLY LOW.
WITH THIS MANY PEOPLE IN THE
PARK, IT'S NOT SURPRISING THIS
TIME OF YEAR THESE THINGS
HAPPEN.
>> I AM GOING TO ASK THE THING I
THINK EVERYBODY IS THINKING.
IT SHOULDN'T BE THAT HARD TO NOT
GO CLOSE TO BISON.
SEEMS LIKE A LOGICAL THING.
SO MY INITIAL QUESTION AS I HAVE
SEEN THESE REPORTS, IS THIS A
SOCIAL MEDIA THING?
IS THIS PEOPLE TRYING TO TAKE
PICTURES?
WHY ARE PEOPLE GOING SO CLOSE
BASED ON YOUR EXPERIENCE?
>> SO I THINK IT'S A BIT OF A
FEW FACTORS.
I THINK FOR SURE SOCIAL MEDIA
HAS BEEN A NEGATIVE INFLUENCE.
PEOPLE ARE RE-CREATING PHOTOS
THEY HAVE SEEN OR A NEW ONE THAT
NO ONE HAS SEEN AND DOING RISKY
BEHAVIORS IS A WAY TO GET THAT
DONE.
ALSO, A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T HAVE
FAMILIARITY WITH REAL AUTHENTIC
WILDLIFE.
WHEN THEY COME TO THE AREAS THEY
THINK THEY ARE VISITING A ZOO.
AND THIS IS NOT A ZOO.
THESE ARE NATIONAL PARKS, TRUE
WILD, AUTHENTIC WILDERNESSES AND
THESE ANSWERS ARE WILD AND
POTENTIALLY DANGEROUS IF WE PUSH
THE LIMITS WITH THEM.
>> WHAT IS YOUR ADVICE TO PEOPLE
IF THEY FIND THEMSELVES -- WE
ARE LOOKING AT SOME SCARY
FOOTAGE THERE -- OF A BISON
CHARGING AT ONE?
WHAT HAPPENS IF YOU ARE IN THAT
SITUATION?
WHAT WOULD YOU ADVISE PEOPLE TO
DO TO BASICALLY SAVE THEMSELVES
FROM BEING SERIOUSLY INJURED OR
PERHAPS EVEN KILLED?
>> SO THE PARK SERVICE IS VERY
CLEAR ON THEIR RULES THAT THEY
HAVE SET FORTH.
THEY ARE NOT JUST POLITE
SUGGESTIONS.
THIS IS THE LAW IN THE NATIONAL
PARKS.
IF YOU ARE IN YOUR CAR, THERE IS
NO RISK.
AS LONG AS YOU ARE PULLED OFF
THE SIDE OF THE ROAD, STOP, ENTO
JOY THE WILDLIFE, TAKE PHOTOS.
IF YOU ARE OUTSIDE OF YOUR CAR,
WALKING, HIKING OR JUST STANDING
ON THE SIDE OF THE ROAD, YOU
NEED TO STAY CERTAIN SAFETY
DISTANCES AWAY FROM THE ANIMALS.
BEARS AND WOLVES, THAT'S 100
YARDS AND ALL OF THE OTHER
ANIMALS, INCLUDING BISON, IS 25
YARDS.
IF YOU SEE THE ANIMAL
DRASTICALLY CHANGING BEHAVIOR
BECAUSE OF YOUR PRESENCE YOU ARE
TOO CLOSE, EVEN IF YOU ARE
BEYOND THOSE LIMITS.
WITH BISON, THEY ARE NICE ENOUGH
TO GIVE US WARNING SIGNS THEY
ARE GETTING AGITATED.
YOU WILL SEE AN EXAGGERATED HEAD
BOBBING, SCRATCHING AND STOMPING
AT THE GROUND.
AND YOU WILL SEE THEIR TAIL GO
UP.
IF YOU SEE ANY OF THOSE FACTORS
HAPPENING, BACK UP, INCREASE THE
AMOUNT OF SPACE BETWEEN YOU AND
THE ANSWER AND LET OTHER PEOPLE
KNOW, TOO, THEY ARE GETTING TOO
CLOSE.
YOU ARE NOT JUST PUTTING
YOURSELF IN DANGER.
YOU ARE PUTTING OTHER PEOPLE IN
DANGER AND PUTTING THE ANIMALS
IN DANGER.